Wow wohohooo
It works
Hey Guys welcome back I'm grant Tomston the king of Random and This is Nate
hey Guys What's Up ,we're pretty Excited for the opportunity to team up with Nickelodeon in this video
to recreate an element from their show
Rusty Rivets
if You Haven't Heard of Rusty Rivets By Now he's a Young hero that uses his imagination and resourcefulness
To save the day When the need arises
in Nickelodeon's New Show Rusty invents His way Out of Every problem By
repurposing spare parts Into The Wildest Coolest and most
Awesome contraptions ever
and a Lot of Them have Been Turned into Toys
so if your Kids are Makers
Experimenters or Rusty Rivets fans then Head down to your local Toys-R-us and Get something to keep Their Hands and Minds Busy
Because Toys R us is the only place That Carries the official line of The Rusty rivets collection
so we watched a part of the show and
For This video we're going to Try
Recreating One of Rusty's inventions but on a Much larger scale
and to Help us test it Out we've Got stuart edge With us today
Dressing Up and Stormy The streets Like a Monkey on the loose
To help us Answer This challenge from Nickelodeon to make a Launcher That Flings Bananas
in One of the episodes
Rusty Saves The City From Monkeys on the loose by creating a Launcher That Shoots Bananas
to lure them back to the Safety of the zoo
We wanted to see if we Could replicate something Similar in real life but Bananas are
a Really Awkward Shape and Not Really Designed to be shot Out of Launchers
so that Just means we Have to get really creative
Now we Spent a lot of time trying to figure out Ways to make a banana
Successfully fire from a Launcher but The laws of Physics Just Generally Aren't in our favor
Bananas By nature are Curved Which means they don't fit Very well down a straight Barrel
They're also Pretty Flimsy so if They're shot with any Type of Force They turn to mush
So true to the spirit of Rusty Rivets we Have tapped our
Imaginations Use a little Teamwork and come up with a Launcher that We Believe Will Actually shoot Bananas
for this project we're using
Pvc pipes a Sprinkler valve some Heavy-Duty springs and a Bit of proto putty
This is all going to come together Pretty quickly but don't Worry Because we'll Explain How everything Works When we Get It Together
Ok We've got all of Our PVC and Abs Pieces Cut for our Blaster
and we're Thinking It might be a good idea Just to paint Them now to save us the trouble down the Road
so Good News Guys We got all of our Pieces cut to size we Got them painted
and that Paint is gonna take a Few Minutes to cure
and while that Paint is drying we're gonna be making our proto putty plug
the Whole idea behind the proto putty is
So we have something that Pushes the banana out of the cannon but then we Retract back into place
so i've cut off a Little Piece of the four inch pVC
we're gonna build the proto putty in there and we're gonna use the end piece of a two inch
Pvc cap as well as an Eye bolt to secure
The proto putty to a really thick rope
there's gonna be a lot of force acting on this and we Don't want This Thing ripping Apart
i forgot To mention we're going to be using two Tubes Of silicone Number one
So we Got all of Our proto putty Packed down and setting Now
it's gonna take about 10 to 20 minutes before we can Actually Take It Out and use It
and While That's curing we're gonna take some of This rope
and build the internal mechanisms for our banana Launcher
We Picked This rope Up from the hardware store and we Got The thick stuff
Because anything Thinner Will Snap
it's in the paracord Section
It's the Thicker Stuff and it's got a Working Load in the Hundreds of Pounds
We're gonna start By cutting off a Six-Foot length of rope and tying The ends together to make a Loop
With our Knot tied in the end secured we're gonna slip it into this metal Clip That we're gonna Run down through This Abs Adapter
And secure it to a thick metal Eye Bolt Fastened on the inside
Okay so now this is going to go through The inside this part is Tricky
There we Go
At This point we've Got Pretty Much everything ready to go
so let's clean Up the proto putty and put everything Together
So here we have it Guys the moment we've Been Waiting for
the cannon is Finished painted and Fully assembled and Ready to test
Out We Grabbed some Red Buckets and decorated them with craft Foam and filled them up with Bananas
so now they look Just like the
Real Rusty Rivets Thing Let's Go find stuart edge Dress Him up in a Monkey costume and go bananas
[in cartoon]: The Banana Launcher on wheels 5000 [Bling sound] [jubilation]
[in cartoon]: Alright time for a Test Launch
[voice from cartoon]: Launching in three
Two
One
[in cartoon]: Huh well That's not strong enough What if we Turn it up to full power
yeah that Should do it
[in cartoon]: Maybe We Should Keep it on medium Power
[in cartoon]: Good idea
Looks like we're in business ,Let's rock
and Now introducing ,the Man ,the myth ,the monkey ,stuart Edge [monkey noises]
Bye bye
Ok ,Ready?
Here we go
Wow wohohoho
Check It out ,Where it Landed ,It Just Like Busted The side out ,that is stuck in there
Wow that Is a powerful Banana Holy heck
Ooh wow
We might Be using a little bit too much Power i think we're gonna have to Turn It down a bit
Ohh, dang it ,that’s so fun to be out there
Three
Two
One
Yehahaha
[happy Laughter]
Yeah
Wohoo
Whoo
Okay here we go
[Laughter]
So update guys banana launcher Is an Epic success
and apparently Depending on the pressure we put into the canon we can Lop Bananas
A Very short distance or we Can Launch Them an epic distance
What I'm Really Impressed about from this Experience is how stewart
Was Able to catch bananas Every single time Without Fail We Should Probably Make This a Sport
i think so
for One Big finish i was Just Thinking What if we Pack This thing full of Ice cream and shot Out a banana split
i saw a Rush to do it so that Probably means We Should too
Three
Two
one
Wooh
Whohohohohohohohoh
[Happy laughter] that wen't a little further than I was expecting
It's All over your face
The Majority of It Though Flu Against The wall Let's Go see That Real quick
yes true to the episode the banana split Does Make
An Epic Mess that Was Crazy look at This This is insane that flu literally like a Hundred Feet?
That's Great You're sweating Ice cream Yeah
So there you have it Guys it'S the Rusty rivets banana Launcher
in real life and even though It's not super practical to shoot Bananas
it'll Launch anything Else That you can shove down the barrel
huge thanks to nickelodeon and Toys R us for helping Make This video Happen
Remember Toys R Us has the official line of all The Rusty Rivets Toys
and They're the only place that you can Get them
we Got The Links and the information for you down in the description go check it out
Go check it out
hey thanks so much for Joining Us for This video Guys we'll Be Looking for you the next one talk to you Then
Wow wohoho
It Works It Works oh ,the cannon blew up
Wow ,ok
Hmm
Yeah, It's a Weird Dry Feeling texture cotton mouth yeah that Except i think i prefer an Actual cotton Ball